foreign
[Music]
Ty what is good we're back it's Thursday
and guess what we got a nice little
wrinkle tonight our boy Greg and our boy
Ryan are on or they're out but we are on
and we have to introduce the man
the winning man
shout out my guy LG bagel and locks how
we doing brother first time on the live
show yeah um I'm feeling good I'm
feeling good this is definitely a new
space for me I'm in The Rat's Nest uh
I'm in producer Ryan's shoes for a
little bit and uh it's cramped in here I
got why he's all all cooped up all day
um normally we open the show by talking
about why last week's parlay did not hit
this week I don't think we're going to
be doing that next week we're definitely
not doing that we're cleaning the Slate
tonight and and I need to see some
winners in the chat yeah
yes sir we're here so if you didn't know
or you were living under a rock my guy
LG won 3 500 parlay over the weekend and
he's coming off his biggest win so we
had to get the Vibes up
all right Logan let me know what you
think about or just tell me a little bit
about how you constructed your parlay
and how and what's the aftermath like
are people asking you for picks now yeah
I mean
so so right off the bat
um when the Chiefs traded Tyree kill
away
I saw the number at 9 50. and I know
that they closed after last year's Super
Bowl around 700 to win it all uh in the
following year and I was just like I had
to grab that number in some capacity so
I deposited more money into the account
100 beans just for this parlay
um I was like there are a couple
constants in life one of them is that
Novak Djokovic will win Wimbledon so I I
added that one in there and golden state
was down 2-1 in the finals and at minus
110 I I thought they're always a great
bet uh had some games at home to make it
up and
we finally got to that last leg Chief
Super Bowl cash out was moving up and
down I had nothing for the two weeks
leading up to the game but
we smacked it that's all that matters we
don't we could stop talking about her
now I don't want to pump up my tires too
much you know I'm I'm absolutely
flattered
um all right we've got some love you got
some love in the chat man people are
welcome that you hit oh I see a producer
Ryan in here calling it The Rat's Nest
yeah that's definitely what we're gonna
call it because it's apparently very
cramped in there brother so
um yeah man wait yeah this I actually
have something that uh producer Ryan
must have left me I don't know if this
was your doing Ryan I don't know what
this is but of course it's his doing man
he's he's the rat he's pushing his
propaganda from everywhere the guy's
boots on the ground at the All-Star Game
in Salt Lake and and I I'm holding up a
sign I love Ryan the guy's hundreds of
miles away
he could always reach us it's good to
know all right should we get into the
chat yeah yeah let's let's get into the
vibes okay
first of all darian85 our loyal fan he
says someone get this man a bagel we
love it we love those vibes drop Bagels
in the chat Bagels in the chat Bagels in
the chat
so Dante cashaw Grayson Allen over
1.53s if you are new to the show we do
not mess with Grayson Allen probs he
sold big time for us so can't really do
anything with that but
we do have some fun stuff in here smoke
gas 420 he sang Drew holiday two threes
so maybe that's a good place to start
true holiday two threes I I did post
something in the community earlier today
and and one of those first comments was
Drew holiday 15 plus points and I
watched their last game and and he's
been stroking it from Deep so let me get
over there
yeah Drew holiday I think will probably
eat I think the the as a the resident
Bulls fan or former Bulls fan we can get
into that a little later but I don't
have any confidence that this team is
going to play any defense they always
sell in the second half and he just
dropped 40 in a comeback win against a
short-handed Celtics team so he's
definitely seeing it well I'm sure he's
looking forward to his time getting back
into the All-Star game after 10 years so
could be a good spot to Target him to
make two threes yes very positive vibes
I also have a Drew holiday Sixers
all-star jersey hard to believe that
those are still in circulation
um so
it's not a coincidence two plus made
threes will start there for sure
um okay I also see key Sneed one
definitely ten boards for vuchevich I've
seen that a bunch might be worth to
check in on that
listen he's hit over 11 and a half and
eight of his last 10 games so I think
that's a good number uh vouch is
probably the most consistent player we
have sold a little bit for us last week
on a game where we needed him to dish it
out that game against the Nets was just
so sloppy so this is a much more
reliable play I would say to get 10
boards and uh yeah and that's not a
that's not about that listen this this
type of parlay is something I would
place on my own but I know this chat
right I know them very well I'm on the
back end every day just reading your
comments during these shows finally I
got a chance to be on the show
um and this is my style this is
something I would place I know you guys
are a part of the get rich Collective
which means that we have to place a five
to one parlay minimum on this show I
won't leave here before the odds are
longer than five to one but this is a
great start I love it
um
Darien sandvouch consistent
yeah he's he's got a point in overall
play I think I'm talking mostly just
rebounds I mean he's had like I said
over 11 and a half he's hit that in
eight of his last ten this has a lot to
do with you know how well obviously the
Bucks play they have more rest the Bulls
played and they're coming in their
second game over back to back tonight so
if we're not feeling 10 boards we can
maybe tease it down or pull it out I
mean all I want to make sure everyone
knows is that we do not need to put too
much stock on this Bulls Bucks game
because they are going to get destroyed
I don't know for a fact it's not going
to be close
yeah I mean I we do have to mention the
Bulls on TNT streak right
something like Bulls at home on TNT
excuse me they've won something like I
think it's 20 straight games uh at home
when they're Primetime on TNT and you
know 20 games seems like a lot but you
know it also seems like they're due to
get absolutely blown out I'm one of
those guys right when you see the when
you see the trend going one way you got
to buy the dip at some point
um
yeah producer Ryan how do we how do we
Okay so I'm seeing some pushback on
vouch I'm happy to remove him because
anything that has anything to do with
the bulls is going to come back to me
and I don't really want that
um I see producer Ryan in here pushing
his propaganda kind of boxes
he's saying bucks money line and I don't
hate that play as a bulls fan I don't
see any way they win this game this is
what they do LG they play terrible
basketball they're on a losing streak
and then when the lights are brightest
they find out a way to keep it close I
could see a path to them potentially
covering seven by losing by seven but I
don't think there's any way they lose
they win this game okay I mean we're
breaking a barrier here are we putting
aside in Chad's part LED chat I want
thumbs up thumbs down just bucks money
line
just yeah how do we feel because we
haven't put aside in one of these so
let's see what the chat thinks I think
Buck's moneyline is a definite lock
darien85 is saying Giannis boards also
don't hate that obviously they just
played in the they're playing in the
second game of back to back the Bulls
are My worry is that this could get out
of hand by the third quarter and he ends
up sitting that's I I think that's a
very fair concern I'm also seeing a lot
of yeah Giannis 30 plus Gianna Sports
um definitely the best player on the
floor I understand why you would wanna
put your money on him but let's just see
what bucks money line does for the
parlay two legs and minus 143. okay I'm
seeing some thumbs down from B tops and
unbox money line some thumbs up all
right thumbs up starting to come in oh a
lot of thumbs up coming in overwhelming
clip
we also got a middle figure Eli Manning
not don't need those vibes come on leave
that alone
[Laughter]
I'm good with this LG minus 143 and we
can have three legs in the second game
which I I obviously believe is going to
be a much better contest so for sure I'm
I'm totally with it let's let's get over
to that second game
um
Superstars right we already got ours we
don't need we don't need to hammer
Superstars but I feel like every week
there's like one guy that we throw in
here that's like kind of off the beaten
path like if you have a strong take
about a player
please drop it in the chat the suns are
like a completely different team now and
KD is not playing yet so I don't know
how sharp we want to try and be but I
think this game is actually going to be
competitive the the spread indicates
that like they think it's going to be a
close game so
I don't know let's see what we get uh
twiers Gala saying CP3 under threes I
wonder what that number is but let's see
that's interesting under threes
I mean I have we ever taken an under in
one of these parlays I don't I don't we
have but it's very very not like it's
not common that's for sure Chris Paul
under one and a half threes we know he's
the mid-range King right he somehow
floats up there hits him from the elbow
um but I'm gonna be sick when Chris Paul
is a three in the first half of this
game you know like I like when the
numbers that one and a half you just
can't you just can't take the under
there I'm sorry I I I totally agree if
it was two and a half I'd definitely be
more interested but we got some more
stuff coming in uh Chris Paul 10 assists
I'm obviously down with that smoke gas
saying take eight and ten to twelve
boards I took Aiden
not that long ago to get I think just
eight and he was just like absent so I
don't know if I'm good with that one but
let's check the assist okay I'm on
Christmas
minus 130 I mean that's a real that's a
real leg right there
um
like his straight number is over nine
and a half and minus 130 makes sense uh
I don't know it's not it's not a play
that scares me I wonder depending on
what else we lock in do we look at what
eight assists is just to kind of be safe
like make it a safe leg I'm with you I'm
with you we want this to hit remember
Ryan's not on the show anymore so
all right eight plus while you're while
you're doing that okay so we're already
in plus money that looks fine to me I
love this I see Tarzan money saying Paul
George
Chris Paul Kauai over on threes that's
gonna be doing too much but yes leads me
to Paul George hit seven out of ten
seven of his last ten he's hit three
threes so maybe that's one that we can
potentially lob in there maybe even
tease it down
let's see two plus threes for Paul
George would be minus 390 okay
Paul George is stubborn he's he's
shooting it he's shooting it from Deep
if it's not even if it's not dropping
which I love I mean I feel the same way
about Drew holiday who um is taking like
20 plus shots a game these days so I'm
happy we added that leg in here
um I'm I like Paul George two plus made
threes I think we could put it in to see
what that does for our payout
all right Plus 173.
so not moving the needle like we needed
to at this point but also not a terrible
play like I said like we said we
obviously need to just like hit this
thing and it's kind of personal for me
and like this competitor in me it's like
we put the two app guys on the show it's
true and if we hit then I have trash
that I can come back and talk to Greg
and to Ryan so maybe I'm pushing a
little bit of an agenda but it's a safe
agenda you feel me for sure all right
yeah no we we take full ownership of
this parlay I'm gonna read the full one
just so everyone gets a feel we're at
four legs right now it's Chris Paul to
record a plus assists in the late game
Paul George two plus made threes in the
late game and then Drew holiday two plus
made threes against the Bulls
and Milwaukee Bucks money line I mean
this would be our first time taking
aside thumbs were very positive in the
chat so I think I think we kind of got a
roll with it at this point yes sir I I'm
saying some interesting plays uh bath I
have boys saying Kawhi 20 plus points
that's probably not going to give us
that much juice but I would definitely
take a look at it
um you know I'm seeing a lot of Joshua
kogi yeah I see Harris who's our MMA
expert in the chat
um I mean that thing would send send
these odds through the roof Josh okogi
is he even on there I don't even see it
I don't I don't see he's nowhere to be
seen
[Laughter]
um here he is here he is
okay the question is do we want to hit
hitchhar parlay on to Harris
we work with Harris you know we'll be
able to to talk to him tomorrow when
when this doesn't smack but well well he
said 15 points that's plus 190. what is
this like 10 points from I mean he has
been playing more I can't imagine it's
that minus 210 he's I mean Harris's take
is he's in a much more expanded role
here
right and obviously not having KD not in
yet like his role is going to diminish
obviously soon so you could imagine he
might be trying to like show what he's
about I don't know if I want to Hitch my
wagon to Joshua kogi but
we got some support we're saying sonoa
42 saying oh kogi is a sneaky play
I don't know I don't know
no no Harris no all caps LOL
um
for 10 safe as F uh
okay uh Rob Dog and producer Ryan are
getting into it in the chat a little bit
I'm I'm not gonna I'm not gonna read
those ones out right now
um uh B Thompson saying bones Highland
plus 105 for 11 points
this is an interesting one if we went 10
it's at minus 140. the only reason why
I'm a little sheepish on this is like
what's his real deal yeah we just got
there like it's kind of like the
opposite of Cam Thomas right like cam
Thomas lit the world on fire and like
Bowen's island has that kind of like
streaky in them I just don't know if
he's gonna get enough run so what do you
think I'm I'm with you there I think I
think it's a little bit risky
um and at minus 140 it's like they're
making the assumption that he's gonna be
even in the rotation we have we have no
idea how much he'll be playing tonight
so I saw in the chat somebody said that
Norman Powell is not playing I don't
know if I can confirm that I'm gonna go
why don't you pop in the chat and see if
you find anything I'm gonna go see if I
can find a a reliable source to confirm
this Norman Pyle thing because that
makes it interesting that means that
bones might
have a chance to make some noise tonight
it's true
okay bones Highland we'll get to threes
I'm seeing man over please oh I
I always like Terence man
over three and a half rebounds with
Powell out all right well bowling's
working on getting the confirmation
um bones is out he is out against the
Phoenix Suns because of knee injury
management
okay so this opens up both the Terence
man and the bones Highland I mean or no
Terence let's see what that number is at
10 plus is minus 140.
hmm I don't I don't hate Terence man
he's definitely much more of a solid
rotation guy and familiar and every time
I bet on Terence man he's cashed so I
have Good Vibes with that all right
actually so we add Terence man in here
we're at plus 375 a little less juicy
than than some of you in the chat might
want
but
if I was kind of lucky I think this is
smacking okay I I just got a note in the
air
from our producer Max
um we need to get this to plus 400 so it
could be eligible for vandals no sweat
promo on the TNT games
right I knew there was a catch okay
let's go let's let's read it out real
quick you can see it on the screen but
we have holiday two plus made threes the
Bucks money line they will win Chris
Paul eight assists I feel like he can do
that in his sleep Paul George's number
is two and a half
and we teased it down to two mm-hmm
let's check on what it looks like if we
just go for the three because the the
suggestions in the chat were that he
would make three threes we just teased
it's a good call it's a good call
all right PG over two and a half threes
all right we're all ready or okay
we're at plus 602 here
I mean
I said I would I said I wouldn't do this
I said I was different see now you know
how high this is
I'm turning into Ryan Ryan but Ryan but
the difference between you and Ryan is
like you had a clear plan
and Ryan just has a clear propaganda
that he wants to just put right Ryan's
here he's like how can I get this play
that I've researched like layered into
this parlay and make it sound like it's
coming from other people you know like
exactly Okay so we've landed in a spot
that's over plus 600 barely obviously
but so let us know in the chat if you're
feeling this parlay five legs plus 602
Drew holiday two plus threes bucks money
line Chris Paul eight assists Paul
George three threes Terence Man 10
points because I'm curious I mean I
don't I obviously like the value in a
plus 600.
you know you put 25 bucks on it you're
coming up over 150 you know it's not bad
Vibe I I know that you had a plan though
so as long as you're good I'm gonna say
I'm good I mean I'm just wondering if we
have an opportunity to to tease some
stuff down and still get in at that over
plus 400 Mark now that we're taking
pgs straight over two and a half threes
prop you know I've something I've taken
I've taken this page out of producer
Ryan's book you know although I do love
to give my guys some tough love he has
taught me some things over these past
couple shows so
um if there's anything you want to tease
down right off the bat like like Chad
drop your most your biggest concern for
this five legger it's in the bottom
right corner Drew holiday two plus mid
threes [__] money line CP 308 plus
assist PG over two and a half threes and
Terence Man 10 plus
we're seeing some positive feedback G
Smith's dropped a lock Emoji Tarzan
money dropped the lock Emoji so Noah
saying I like that ticket fellas PG
might fry but still I think we would be
more happy and I don't listen this is up
for interpretation this is how I feel I
would feel personally more safe taking
two threes from Paul George and then
maybe playing around with the Terence
man leg but it sounds like the the chat
is
maybe okay so Tarzan money saying man to
eight and a half points what's his uh
what's his straight uh over under all
right because that could be a good solve
Player points
Terence Mann is at ten and a half
yeah so that's tough I mean like the
books expect them to get 10 like I said
he has not
he has not failed me so I love having
him in there and I I am safe with the 10
if we can't get it down to eight and a
half I think we just leave that as is
yeah I mean
I like Terence man at 10 plus I think we
could if we wanted to drop down
pg3s or Drew threes we could go up on
Chris Paul assists if we want true I
mean Chris Paul's assist numbers and I'm
gonna try and pull him up right now he
has definitely hit this number a bunch
he had 19 assists I think not too long
ago a couple games ago so
here's the last few games well I don't
know the numbers aren't supporting my
argument as well okay okay he had 19
against the Kings 9 8 12 14 8. that's
his last handful game so I think eight
is like as safe as we can be I like to
make sure that's a lot plus assists
um
okay I'm seeing take Terence man over
ten and a half it pays -12 while 10 plus
pays minus 140. and and I think he's
right right like the yep the juice is
worth the squeeze for half a point yeah
and then we can definitely knock
something down
so yeah let's make that swap real quick
I think then that puts us in a position
to take Paul George just two threes yep
and then we won't feel like we have to
die by the hook
because dime by the hook is like the
worst thing ever the worst a nightly
basis I'm dying by the hook
[Laughter]
it's true all right pg2 plus made threes
okay okay that's nice plus four that's
nice one it's like close to a pretty
round number
I mean I'm I'm cool with this let's
let's read it out one more time and
let's do full on thumbs up thumbs down I
know bath that boy really wants the
Greek Freak we are worried about a
blowout bath that boy we know what the
Greek Freak can do
you know the problem the problem with
taking Giannis in a spot like this is
this game might be over in the second
quarter and he's gonna want to rest I
mean he's going to the all-star game so
he's not going to rest that whole time
like I could totally see him not even
playing the entire fourth quarter
tonight so I don't really want to take
him at 30 points ooh it's just like it
seems like too much I'm with you totally
with you he's a little
I mean he's so consistent right and what
his Line's going to be at like 33 and a
half let's check let's check you on his
points
um it's gonna be astronomical like it's
no fun
because then you need him to like stay
in the game yeah 35 and a half no way
let's bet on somebody to score 36 points
at minus 102. yeah now
no thank you
um all right read the Parliament that we
got let's see what we let's see what we
get from uh from the chat all right we
got true two plus three points man
Milwaukee Bucks money line Chris Paul 8
plus assists the point got himself PG
two plus three points made
Terence man over 10 and a half points
we're sending that plus 451 and you can
get the no sweat parlay promo through
our friends of FanDuel I mean
I'm ready to sit back kick my feet up
you know watch these tips and and win
some money that we're we're turning the
page it's a new leave today
I'm feeling good yeah we're good to go
man like we said we're aligned on we
think the Bulls are going to get boat
raced and we think this is going to be a
good game in the second half of the
doubleheader I like this it's safe it
involves a lot of key players we put we
took a side
we we kind of Switched the vibe up and I
like it so if you're ready to lock it in
I'm ready to lock it in I'm ready I
think I'm ready to call it I'm seeing
lock emojis um B Thompson I'm going to
read out I do see some thumbs down you
know Ryan will ignore these thumbs down
um I I do see them I like it
okay okay yeah no I think we're in a
good spot B Thompson 1992 awesome always
showing up for the show let's lock it in
he is pushing bones Highland tonight
which we said we didn't hate but we're
both aligned on Terence man so I say we
lock it in man we're good to go let's do
it all right parlay's locked parlay is
locked screenshot
screenshot usually it's me taking the
screenshot
um
a little more meta tonight
um I did want to shout something out
obviously you and I have talked about it
but Squad ride for tonight
yes you ready hell yeah so last night
bk37 gave out his gift cards from our
prop contest over the weekend and one of
them went to Chef drew312
who then doubled down and gave us a
squad ride cam Thomas over points and it
hit I think almost at halftime
so we're letting him get another shot
tonight and he is going with
Kawhi Leonard over 34 and a half points
rebounds and assists it's minus I think
108 on FanDuel right now
LG let me know what you think about it
and I want the chat to let us know their
grade on tonight's Squad ride listen I I
love this squad ride I mean first of all
I'd love to see them the making the
Inception of a new community Legend we
had a heater last week where we got up
to hitting five straight Squad rides
we're in the green up just over two
units on Squad ride so far this year and
Kawhi has cleared this number in 12 of
his last 15 and I mean no better Vibes
than going for back-to-back winners in
the community so I'm all over it I
already placed it straight
um I wish we could add it to the parlay
points I wish you could add points
rebounds assist to the parlay because I
love it
they gotta give us a chance to do that
um so yeah so I'm obviously on it as
well I tailed I put a couple units on
the the cam Thomas play I'm a Vibes guy
as you know so I'm not gonna jump off
the train while it's you know cooking
down the track I think that it's a good
play Grim gorilla saying that's a lock
on Kauai Tarzan money Squad ride 100
emoji lots of it looks like Euro cash so
shout out to the squad tonight if you
know you know hop into the stream go and
tail and now
we get to grade the the chats bets I
wonder what producer Ryan is on I see
he's in here pushing his propaganda but
let us know your bets for tonight and
we're gonna put some grades on them I'm
gonna start personally with the bone
tile and stuff
okay I don't want anyone to think we are
anti-bone Thailand people because I
think bones I wanted Bones on the Bulls
but the Bulls as always don't make any
moves when they need to so I'm kind of
sad that he's not here but I think if
he's in the rotation enough
he's going to score a lot of points he's
as streaky as they come so thoughts on
Bones Highland it's true I mean Bones is
like one of those guys uh you see in the
park playing basketball on the weekend
like his game is straight from the
blacktop like we're playing 2K like he
carries the ball in every play that's
what my dad says but we don't have to we
don't have to get into that but I mean
yeah he's a certified walking bucket I
mean like at 10 and a half points that's
that's a really solid number I mean we
just
we're a little we're trying to be a
little risk-averse you know without the
rat himself on the show
um and that's really my take I just
think we're trying to be a little more
conservative
um not saying he can't pop off for 15
plus though tonight
for sure I totally agree I went up and
checked Chef Drew who we just shouted
out said Zach Levine over five and a
half boards at plus a hundred thoughts
on that
I mean Zach Levine boards it's a little
personal here I'm trying to get rid of
all bias like I've I've been ruined by
Zach lavine's boards prob
um and and I like vooch at for a similar
price at 10 plus like way more than that
so
um that that's where I would go I'm
gonna grade it like
I'll give it a c though
yeah I mean like he's he's cleared that
number a couple times
um but as a bulls fan you just don't
know what Zach you're gonna get
like Zach can come out really engaged
one night and like Drop 25 with five and
five or give you 30 with like six boards
and a handful of assists like
I feel like after last night's blown
game against the Pacers like they might
just sleep walk through this thing
because you literally are 48 minutes
away from taking a vacation with your
family yeah look at it I don't see the
motivation being very high at all for
the Bulls um another one I saw Tito 585
says porzingis over 23 and a half I'm
assuming that's points
just to give some love to uh the non-tnt
games what do you think about that one
I'm gonna check that one out just see
what the line is or like
what that number is at over 23 and a
half
um producer Ryan says he can't bet in
Utah can't drink in Utah so he's reading
a lot he's reading a book tonight you
should probably try and read something
about
the people and how to engage with the
people and how not to push your
propaganda but be a listener more than a
talker and just maybe just like come
back with some new energy next week you
know I think we're we're doing our best
to hold down the fort this week but you
got an opportunity to change the Vibes
up producers it's true so that's my
advice listen we're not trying to pin
this all on producer Ryan you know I
mean there's other people on the show
who do give out their picks I mean but
this this parlay is made up of strictly
picks from the community strictly picks
from the chat and and when when we send
this alert out to your phone with this
parlay I don't want to see comments like
oh these never hit like oh this it's
like you guys make these like you put
you put them in here bowling and I talk
about the picks and then
and then we place them in a parlay and
we ride so I think tonight is a great
opportunity
I think there's no other way to describe
this as like
we we let you guys push the parlay
propaganda and we evaluate and then we
place and we all lose together like I've
lost on these parlays I haven't just
been putting a dollar on them so I'm in
the trenches just as much as you are and
uh we don't want to win that's it that's
the only thing we want to do we want to
take fanduel's money
and I think that's what we're going to
do tonight
yeah no I'm I'm pumped I mean
I might just lock this in right now but
yeah okay so I gotta I gotta one last
grade and then we'll get out of here so
we can place the parlay and obviously
finish working
um specko am I invisible I already gave
us three legs in this last few weeks but
was invisible but it's okay I have
tonight Conley over six and a half
assists Bulls bucks under 230 lock I'm
out that's pretty that's pretty fun
and the way he wrote it too like let's
there's that's personal like am I am I
invisible
I gave it's like a bars and then you do
like my mic drop at the end I'm out I
mean like just because of
of the confidence like I I have to give
that
at least in a minus like yeah I'm I'm a
line a minus I think the reasons why
Conley is an assist machine
Bulls bucks under 230. I'm expecting a
blowout so that's not a bad play
so you get an A you get an A minus for
both of us I don't think that's ever
happened in the history of the show
so yeah this is good stuff LG I'm glad
you were able to tap in with me and tap
in with the community what are your
thoughts man first show under the books
how you feeling I'm feeling good man
this is fun I mean I got why
like I said earlier The Rat's Nest is
very tight I'm not gonna lie I get why
producer Ryan's going a little bit wild
in here but I mean this was an absolute
blast like I I interact with the
community uh through bagel and locks but
to actually talk to them hear their
takes on tonight's NBA slate has been
unreal
um
godspeed manifest I'm ready to catch
this thing should we read the parlay one
more time can we Flash the parlay back
on the screen one last time
so we have drew holiday two made threes
Milwaukee Bucks money line I think
that's the luckiest leg of the entire
thing
Chris Paul eight assists Paul George two
made threes Terence man over ten and a
half points I'll see you at the cashier
brother yes sir
let's go let's get this dub shout out to
everyone in the community for tailing
and let's have a night we are out of
here peace
foreign
[Music]